what we're going to do in this video is
think about how to visualize
distributions of data then to analyze
those visualizations and we will
eventually get to something known as a
density curve but let's start with a
simple example just to review some
concepts let's say I go to 16 students
and I ask them to measure how many
glasses of water they drink per day for
the last 30 days and then to average it
and so this data point right over here
tells us one student drank an average of
0.5 glasses of water per day that person
is probably very dehydrated this person
drank 8.1 glasses of water per day on
average for the last 30 days they are
better hydrated if we want to visualize
that we can set up a frequency histogram
where we can create some categories so
this first category would be 4 data
points that are greater than or equal to
0 and less than 1 and we can see that
two data points fall into that category
and that's why the bar right over here
for that category is up to two this
category right over here is greater than
or equal to 3 and less than 4 notice
there are four data points in that
category and on this frequency histogram
the height of the bar is indeed 4 so
this is a nice way of looking at a
distribution but you might be more
concerned with what percentage of my
data falls into each of these categories
and that becomes especially interesting
if we have many many many many data
points and if we had you know 1 billion
600 million 430 2507 data points well
just knowing the absolute number that
fit into each category isn't so useful
the percent that fits into each category
is a lot more useful and so for that we
could set up a relative frequency
histogram so notice this is representing
the same data but in that first category
instead of the bar height being to the
bar height is now 12.5%
why is that because two of the 16 data
points fall into the
category 216 is 1/8 which is 12.5% in
this one right over here notice instead
of the height being 4 4 4 data points
it's now 25% but these are saying the
same thing 4 out of the 16 data points
fall into this category 4 16 is 1/4
which is 25% so both of these types of
histograms
are really useful and you will see them
used all of the time but there are also
cases where you have many many many more
data points and you want more granular
categories so what you could do is well
let's just make our categories a little
more granular so for example instead of
them being one glass of water why maybe
make them half a glass of water wide so
this first category could be greater
than or equal to 0 and less than 0.5 and
that will give you a clearer picture and
I'm now assuming a world where we have
more than 16 data points maybe we have
16 million data points this would be
percentages on the left-hand side but
maybe that isn't good enough for you
maybe you want to get even more granular
so you make everything each category a
quarter of a glass but maybe that
doesn't satisfy you want to get more and
more and more granular well you could
imagine where this is going you could
get to a point where you're approaching
an infinite number of categories and
each category is infinitely thin is
super super thin to a point that if you
just connect the tops of the bars that
you will actually get a curve and this
type of curve is something that we
actually use in statistics and as
promised at the beginning of the video
this is the density curve we talked
about and what's valuable about a
density curve it is a visualization of a
distribution where the data points can
take on any value in a continuum they're
not just thrown into these coarse
buckets so how would you interpret
like this if you look over the entire
interval from zero let's say to nine
assuming no one drank more than an
average of nine glasses per day even in
our 16 million data points well then the
area under the curve over that interval
is going to be one hundred percent or
one point zero this is going to be true
for any density curve that the entire
area of the curve is 100% it represents
all of the data points a density curve
will also never take on a negative value
you won't see the curve dip down and do
something strange like that now with
that out of the way let's think about
how we would make use of it if I wanted
to know what percentage of my data falls
between two and four glasses well I
would look at that interval I'd go from
two to four I would look at this
interval right over here and I would try
to figure out the area under the curve
here and this area is going to be
greater than or equal to zero and less
than or equal to 100% when I I ball
right over here it looks like it's about
40% of the entire area under the curve
so just eyeballing it I would say
roughly 40% of my data falls into this
interval if I were to ask you what
percentage of the data is greater than
three well then you would be looking at
this area and it looks like it is about
50% but once again I am estimating it
but you can start to see how even with
estimation a density curve could be
useful
in the real world statisticians will
often have tables that might represent
the information for the density curve
they might have computer programs or
some type of automated tool and there
are also well known density curves the
famous bell curve that we will study
later on where there's a lot of precise
data and a lot of tools to exactly
figure out the areas the last thing I'd
like to
is a key misconception for density
curves if I were to ask you
approximately what percentage of my data
is exactly three glasses of water per
day and when I say exactly I mean
exactly the number three point zero zero
zero zeros goes just going on and on
forever the exact number three well you
might be tempted to just say okay this
is three let me see the corresponding
point on the curve it looks like it is
about zero point two or a little higher
than that so maybe you would say a
little bit more than twenty percent or
approximately twenty percent and what I
would say to you is this is wrong
remember the percentage of the data and
an interval is not the height of the
curve it is the area under the curve in
that interval and if we're just talking
about one precise value like exactly the
number three there is no area under the
curve this vertical line that I just
drew over the number of three has no
width and this actually makes sense in
the real world even if you were to look
at 16 million people it is very unlikely
that even anyone would drink exactly
three glasses of water per day I'm
talking about not one atom or or one
atom less than three glasses there might
be many people between two point nine
and three point one but no one is
exactly three glasses a day when someone
says I'm drinking three glasses of water
per day that'd be a rough estimate there
probably three point zero zero zero one
or two point nine nine nine nine nine or
three point one five or whatever else
and so instead you could say what
percentage falls into in the interval
maybe that is greater than or equal to
two point nine and less than or equal to
three point one and so once you have an
interval then you actually can look at
the area so we're going to go from two
point nine to three point one so now we
have an interval that actually has width
and so it'd be roughly the size of this
yellow area that I'm shading in right
over here and we can approximate it with
a
even though the top of this curve isn't
flat but we could say look it's
approximately like a rectangle that is
0.2 high and what's the width the width
here for going from 2.9 to 3.1 the width
is going to be 0.2 wide and so we could
approximate this area by approximating
this rectangle the area of the rectangle
0.2 times 0.2 that would give us an area
of 0.04 or we could say approximately 4
percent of the data falls in this
interval